na ja danke danke meine damen und herren
dankeschön dankeschön dankeschön dann
gehts dann aber doch die presse hier ich
habe heute geburtstag meine damen und
herren dankeschön wäre ja danke danke
könnte echt angst mal aufhören
anlässlich meines geburtstags habe ich
euch ja schon mitgeteilt dass dieser
rudi hier vor zwei stunden gelaunter
punkten von diesem rudi gibt es nur 1000
exemplare also es limitiert zu jeder
bestellung erhaltet ihr eine von mir
signiertes ticker karte jaschek gern mal
den job habe ich weiß nicht ob überhaupt
noch welche da sind allerdings soll es
heute nicht um diesen rudi gehen oder
meinem geburtstag sondern um hobby horse
-ing
falls ihr nicht wisst was das ist hobby
horse ist eine sportart mit gymnastik
elementen bei der bewegungsabläufe
ähnlich derer beim springreiten oder
dressur teilweise in parks nachgestellt
werden ohne dass echte pferde zum
einsatz kommen stattdessen benutzen die
teilnehmer überwiegend selbst gefertigte
steckenpferde und das bild was auf
dieser wikipedia-seite dazu angepinnt
wurde ist das hier ja das ist hobby
horse lng und heute reagieren wir
zusammen auf ein video von einer hobby
horse drin mit dem titel hobby horse lng
treffen mit den speed riders deutsch
german ich bin gespannt
ok also dass hier sind wohl ihre
steckenpferde hast also die hat vier
stück
aha obwohl ich hab ich versprochen und
zu drehen und ja hier ist okay also
heute findet das treffen der riders
start des betreibers ist eine hobby
horse lng truppe aus der nähe von
frankfurt bestehend aus mehreren hobby
horse an
also mädels und vielleicht auch jüngst
das weiß ich nicht die ein steckenpferd
sich zwischen die beine klemmen und über
hindernisse springen hat ist ein hund
achtung
[Musik]
was
als er das war richtig gut also erst mal
sorry dass ich euch hier gerade keinen
ton einblenden konnte aber das ganze
sind lizenz geschützte lieder und dass
der girls ley
das war ein guter sprung alter
[Musik]
okay sie grüße anscheinend immer leute
hier kannst du mich bitte im nächsten
block grüßen einen kuss und herz da
vielleicht kriegt jetzt ausschaut und
auch mit 4g hat momentan können stock
doch scheiße also diese verschiedenen
fertigen steckenpferde hier von ihr
haben tatsächlich eigenen namen
das hier ist silber sowie ich das
richtig verstanden habe uns silva wird
auf jeden fall mitgenommen zum hobby
horse in speed riders treffen
legt man wichtige schenken und ich
angefragt aber es ist ein doppelt so und
ein wichtiges schenk alter ok
anscheinend nehmen die das ganze
wirklich ziemlich ernst ich bin ganz
ehrlich mit euch freuen ich möchte nicht
dass irgendjemand dieses video von der
hobby horse lng unterstrich de ich will
nicht dass irgendjemand dieses video
hated oder diese person oder dieses
speed riders truppe ganz im gegenteil
ich finde das hobby horse ting genauso
real tag genauso im sport ist wie
parkour oder fußball oder keine ahnung
was ich weiß natürlich sieht lustig aus
wenn die sonne stock zwischen beiden
haben mit zum fährt oben drauf von
pferdekopf zum stofftier steckenpferd
und dann springen über hindernisse
natürlich klar ist dass ein bisschen
lustig aber sie sagt selber hier auch in
einem kommentar ich wusste nicht einmal
dass es sowas gibt aber werdet ihr nicht
ausgelacht oder so manchmal schon ist
uns aber egal also die youtuber rede
hier weiß selbst dass es wahrscheinlich
für außenstehende die keine ahnung davon
haben die sehen halt erstmal ja da sind
mädels die reiten wie auch stofftiere
fährten und springen über hindernisse so
natürlich kichert man da erst mal ein
bisschen aber es soll wirklich überhaupt
nicht negativ sein und falls jemand von
euch auch hobby horse ist alter ich habe
respekt davor weil ohne schilt dieser
sprung alt er war schon echt gut
[Musik]
das ist quasi wie leichtathletik nur mit
einem pferd den kopf
also werden wir uns jetzt diesem blog
hier weiter anschauen und wenn jetzt
gleich zu ihrer tour und zu dem
wettkampf und dem hobby horse hinkommen
und ich dachte ein bisschen abbauen
werde
da nimmt es mir bitte nicht böse ich
nehme dieses strick und bei alter falls
jemand von euch da draußen auf hoher see
ist habt ihr auch so einzelne zügel und
stricke und dressur stock und ganz viel
das ist ja wahrscheinlich ein echt
teures equipment neustadt die haben sie
jetzt getroffen mit ihrer hobby hosting
gruppe und haben sich gegenseitig
wichtig geschenke für ihre hobby horses
mitgebracht alter ich bin schon was die
freunde hat man klar an jedem video bist
du es bist mein gott sie hat sogar ihre
pferde als hintergrund war die sorge
schon nervös hier
diese ganz nervös vor ihrem wettkampf ok
die packen jetzt weiterhin ihre wichtige
geschenke aus die sache ist hier vorne
gehen sie glauben
[Musik]
also leute versteht mich damit sie nicht
falsch wir haben früher auch als wir
noch in einer grundschule waren oder
fünften sechsten klasse irgendwelchen
bescheuerten rollenspiele gemacht okay
das ist jetzt echt ein bisschen pervers
an ich glaube wir uns dann 23 jähriger
junge gesehen hätte auch gedacht was ist
halt schon deren kopf ach du ach du
grüne neune
jetzt kommt die nächste mein gott mehr
treiben hallo mein gott jetzt haben sie
sich da auch ein parcours aufgebaut wo
mein gott was macht sie denn jetzt
kommen wir zurück und jetzt muss ich
darüber springen alter okay das war gut
und da hinten um mein gott okay der
werse fast gestolpert
man muss wirklich sagen es ist so eine
mischung aus leichtathletik
es ist eigentlich leichtathletik also no
shit okay das ist schon krass ehrlich
gesagt ich glaube sie hier ist dann
irgendwie so die anführerin oder so
walter rusche da war das war schon hoch
[Musik]
also ich weiß nicht ich lache darum war
so ein bisschen aber ich glaube ich
könnte ja nicht zu bringen also wir
gehen jetzt gleich gleich noch aus
solltest du schon
ausreiten laufen die dann damit durch
den wald oder was das ausreiten junge
clara dies immer hässlich bescheuert
alex ist alex ist schade
mein gott 15 ihr müsst halten da steht
man überlegen die haben so ein stock
zwischen den beinen noch jetzt auch mein
gott leute sie reiten aus naja
ok naja hat sie gerade also wirklich
kompletten respekt dafür für den sport
in meinen laufschritt ich habe früher
mit einem kumpel von mir dieses becher
stapeln gemacht wie higher speed cup
cups keine ahnung wie das genau heißt es
war so becher die konten aufstellen die
hatten so spezielle löcher drin für luft
dings und dann konnte man ganz schön
zusammen machen dann gab es richtig
wettkämpfe davon nur blabla also ich
hatte früher auch ein komisches hobby
von daher kann ich genau nachvollziehen
wie ihr euch mehr oder weniger fühlt
weil hobby horse ist zumindest in
deutschland der randsportart ist ich
glaube in finnland gibt sogar richtige
nationale meisterschaften und turniere
aber ich habe wirklich komplett und
respekt davor weil ich meine es ist
einfach nur leichtathletik mit einem
pferd und ich meine wenn man jetzt nicht
reiten möchte mit einem richtigen pferd
oder weil man davor angst haben oder ich
meine du kannst du auch nicht zu jeder
uhrzeit mit diesem pferd dann reiten
eines hobby horse ich glaube ich eine
gute alternative
aber dass man dann mit dem pferd naja
das ist in der tat ein wenig wind gerade
was denken sich dieses schafe kommen eh
schon viele andere menschen an wo die
sich denken hey was wollen denn die
menschen jetzt wandern reiten die
menschen auch noch auf so werde
stofftiere mit einem stock im kopf der
platzes jahr mini und die harmlose aber
das verstehe ich zwischendurch nicht
jetzt galoppieren die da los man kann
eigentlich die nicht fertig machen das
muss man mal so sagen ließ ja auch
überhaupt nicht meine intention aber ich
weiß halt wie die youtube community
manchmal drauf ist deswegen möchte ich
euch direkt sagen leute ich verlinke
euch das video bitte lasst denen ganz
viel liebe da ich finds mega mega süß in
der tat ein bisschen komisch aber
begrüßt halt wirklich echt interessant
aber man muss wirklich mal sagen wenn
jemand wissen zurückspulen dass er schon
das ist schon eine krasse hobby hosting
ist in meinen augen jetzt natürlich
nicht so krasser sport im volksmund wie
fußball oder basketball oder handball
cetera pp aber es ist auf jeden fall ein
sport- und es sollte auch ernst genommen
werden findet obwohl das hier natürlich
echt ein bisschen bescheuert aussieht
mit diesem verband allerdings ist echt
interessant und wie bereits gesagt habe
ich einfach einen artikel gelesen in dem
drinstand hobby horse lng soll der neue
trendsport unter den mädels trainingstag
mit den speed riders also die speed
riders youtuber rinn hier hat auf jeden
fall einige videos zum hobby horse in
hochgeladenen jedes video traurigen die
über 30.000 aufrufe also sie spricht
damit auf jeden fall auch einige leute
an wollen daher wenn euch meine reaktion
hierauf hobby hosting gefallen hat dann
lasse gerne einen daumen hoch bei diesem
video da schreibt mir gerne und in die
kommentare ob ich noch mal auf so etwas
reagieren soll schreibt mir vielleicht
auch und in die kommentare ob du selbst
das machst oder schon mal gemacht hat
oder ob dir schon mal davon gehört habt
ich noch nicht
[Musik]